[Musique]
bonsoir nos petits amis
ce soir il faut être très gentil avec
notre nounours il est très enrhumé le
pauvre allons un peu de courage mon cher
nounours descend fit dire bonsoir à
nicolas et pimprenelle et nous irons
nous coucher au merci patron c'est ce
qui peut me faire le plus de bien
une bûche seule pompe aux pauvres
nounours enrhumé c'est vrai que tout
brûlant de la vienne
tiens on voit ta petite bouche on va
prendre la température oui c'est ne rien
aux poudres eu poteau tétouan où tu vas
faire monter la fièvre au petit non ce
ne parle pas surtout tu vas voir avant
taxes wendy mes piqûres et après tu
seras tugar et vous proposera le coup si
l'âge ne nous est malade et ochoa n'y
voyons un peu ta températures le
thermomètre
olala temps une fièvre une fièvre de
cheval
nicolas à port tudy de quoi soigner nous
nous reprenons
[Musique]
oh
voilà madame la dernière ouvre la bouche
nous on te fais un petit manège en bleu
attention là ça y est et maintenant
maintenant les contempler vital et ne
bouge pas comme ça bouge pas houle a
maintenant maintenant une bonne friction
ma vie normale du petit roux dans la
peur c'est ça c'est ça on vous la bouche
mal et là je vais te faute et bien
fortune afin aussi font hollow messieurs
savait très chanceux du dieu ça répond
nicolas
pendant ce temps je vais lui mettre
quelques retouches malades
outre le bronze alors oui c'est pour toi
n'annonce une dame et melior
un chercheur dieu soit loué à l'eau
emilia oui c'est moi
nounours ça va très bien merci
oh ils veulent venir
eh bien je vais les chercher tout de
suite au revoir mon petit lapin hors
bois mes petits neveux veulent venir
passer quelques jours chez vous on va
vite les gars on est là comme ça tu
auras pas quoi tu t'en rimera plus
[Musique]
je pars vite chercher ces trois
charmants petits oursons au revoir les
autos avec les filles par écrit enfin
les enfants
bonne nuit à la noce
on voyage bon voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que nounours va déjà mieux
alors mon pauvre grand malade
oh oui patron ça va beaucoup mieux je
suis si content que mes petits neveux
viennent en vacances chez pas preneuse
nicolas alors en route allant vite et
cherchait et vous mes petits amis
en attendant de connaître rémi toto et
fanfan aller vite au dodo et faites de
beaux rêves
bonne nuit bonne nuit
[Musique]